[Music]
elizabeth is in baltimore hi elizabeth
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thanks so much how's it going
better than i deserve how can we help
so
i am about 22 years old i'll be 23 um
this coming june so i right now um i
have a pretty good job i work in the
city i i live on my own in my own
apartment um and i'm i consider myself
debt-free only because my mom i'm lucky
enough that my mom pays off my student
loans that's how i'm building credit
though right now i don't have a credit
card
um i'm kind of
trying to figure out how to start
building my credit in the best way and i
also hope to in like the next maybe
five to seven years start look at maybe
building a house building a house
somewhere but inflation is kind of
scaring me recently so i'm trying to
figure out what is my best way to set
myself up for a success since i'm at a
kind of i guess good point in my life
where i don't have so much debt you are
so cool you're on the ball for 22. well
done thank you very cool and you're new
to us how did you find us
um so actually i've since i've been so
into um you know home builds and all
that stuff recently um there was a girl
on tick tock i can't remember her name
but she talked about how she paid off i
think 350 thousand dollars of debt so
you jumped over and found us where
um so she i found you guys on spotify
and she told me i was listening to you
um
so i was like i gotta go take a listen
elizabeth what we teach what we teach
folks is the shortest distance between
where you are and wealth is to get out
of debt and stay out of debt
because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income
okay now that you need to have that you
need to have that framework for me to
answer this question
because what that would mean is is that
i don't want you going in debt
that's what it means right and so what
that means is you're not going to go in
debt to build your credit so that you
can build your debt so that you can go
into debt to build your credit so that
you can go into debt to build your
credit so that you can go into debt to
build your credit which is what people
do with the fico score
the fico score does not mean anything a
high fico score all it means is you've
been playing kissy face with the bank
it does not mean you have money
it does not mean you have money
yeah it means you paid the bank your
money that's all it means so i i don't
want it's a false measure of winning
it's a lie
and you're not winning if you have a
high fico score if you have an 800 fico
score i'm sorry for you you paid
probably a hundred thousand dollars in
interest to build that
yeah somebody else
it's kind of like playing those video
games where you buy stuff for your video
game it's not real right yeah so don't
do it don't go build your credit
elizabeth you know what my credit score
is i have no idea that's what it is i
don't know we don't have one could care
less we quit borrowing money we don't
have a credit score how do you get a
mortgage you do manual underwriting
remember that phrase
when you get ready to build elizabeth
manual underwriting but the fastest way
that you get ready to out do inflation
and get to build your house is stay out
of debt don't go into debt so you can
have the opportunity to go into debt so
that you can build your score so that
you can have the opportunity to go into
debt so that you can build your score so
that you can have the opportunity to go
into debt don't get caught up in the rat
chasing its wheel and keep these banks
furniture bought for them
buy your own furniture